this episode is brought to you by 99
designs the global creative platform
that makes it easy for you to find and
work with amazing graphic designers
online long time listeners of this
podcast know how much attention i paid
to detail
how obsessively i approach nearly all
elements of my work because the small
things often end up being the big things
so whether it's your logo
your business cards website design even
your email templates all of these visual
elements tell your customers tell your
users
who you are and what you're about so i
think it's worth sweating the details
i've been using 99 designs for years now
to ensure that many of my creative
projects whether big or small
are as cohesive professional and
beautiful as possible
i've worked on draft mock-ups of book
covers
i've worked on all sorts of things most
recently i've been working with a
designer at 99 designs to update the
illustrations and layouts for all of my
downloadable ebooks
i've developed a really great working
relationship with the designer who goes
by
the username spoon and i intend to
continue working with him to bring ideas
to life one project at a time
i've also used 99designs for all sorts
of high-end illustration for different
books like the tao of seneca you can see
a bunch of examples on my instagram that
i've put up
and they've turned out better than i
possibly could have hoped
so from logos to websites to packaging
to books
99designs is the go-to creative resource
to build your brand on any budget
so check them out right now my listeners
that's you guys can get 20
off plus a free 99 upgrade on
their first design contest contest is a
great way to get started and find the
right designer
for long-term work you can also book a
free design consultation with a brand
expert at 99designs to receive
personalized branding advice over the
phone
their hands-on team has helped thousands
of business owners at this point
it's a great way to get the most out of
your experience with 99 designs
so take a look head to 99designs.com
tim for your discount and to sign up for
design consultation today
that's 99designs.com tim
this podcast is brought to you by the
ready state virtual mobility coach
what on earth is that well let me back
up the first person
i personally call for help with my
athletic recovery or mobility training
is dr kelly starrett at the ready state
i've known kelly for more than a decade
i was introduced to him
for a bunch of reasons i've seen him
perform near miracles
on me and many others he's a good friend
but he's also a mobility
and movement coach for olympic gold
medalists world champions and pro
athletes you might recognize the name
because kelly was
in the four-hour body he was in tools of
titans he's been on this podcast
he also nursed and coached me through
the
destroy my body for entertainment tv
show that was the tim ferriss experiment
and i made it through those 13 episodes
because
of kelly would not have survived now
kelly has created a program called
virtual mobility coach it's like
carrying
a virtual kelly starrett in your pocket
because most people are not going to
have
direct access to kelly but now you do
every day virtual mobility coach gives
you guided mobility videos walks you
step by step
through kelly's proven techniques to
relieve pain
improve range of motion improve
performance on and on and on and on
there are a lot of things you can do
with this program and you got to check
it out it's
encyclopedic but simultaneously really
easy to navigate
if you're in pain you can pull up a
picture of the human body click on what
hurts and from there
get customized regimen to help find
relief
if you are working out or playing a
sport virtual mobility coach
offers all sorts of pre and post
exercise mobility sequences
for more than 50 sports and activities
actually so those will help you warm up
before your workout so you can run
faster
jump higher lift heavier all with a
lower risk of injury
and if you're not in pain or working out
virtual mobility coach also has a
library of daily maintenance videos
great way to speed up recovery on your
off days which also helps a lot with
sleep much of that stuff
and right now listeners of this podcast
get a special deal you can try
virtual mobility coach you can get the
kelly starrett in your pocket
totally risk-free for two weeks without
paying a penny it is a two-week
free trial so you should try it out
kelly is super legit
he is literally the person i text and
call with the most
sophisticated slash esoteric questions
about recovery and injuries i've
inflicted upon myself
he knows what he's doing and his stuff
really really works try it completely
free for two weeks and if you decide to
continue
you can get 10 off for life using promo
code
tim10 that's tim10
simply visit therestate.com tim to check
everything out
and use code tim10 at checkout again
that's the readystate.comtim
and use codetim10 when you sign up to
get 10 off for the life of your
membership
after your 14 day free trial ends the
readystate.com
tim at this altitude i can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start
shaking
can i answer your personal question now
with
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show i'm
going to keep my usual preamble short i
want to get to the meat
and potatoes of this conversation with
stephen ranella instagram
meateater stephen ranella he is the host
of the netflix original series
meat eater and the meat eater podcast
he's also the author of seven books
dealing with wildlife conservation
hunting fishing and wild foods
including the meat eater guide to
wilderness skills and survival
which is his newest and you can find it
now
on the web you can find all things
stephen vanella at themeateater.com
and then on facebook he is stephen
ranella that's with a v
steven ranella r-i-n-e-l-l-a meat
eater steve welcome back to the show
thank you for having me on i appreciate
it man
i have so many questions for you in part
because you
are not just an expert in
survival wilderness skills but you
actually practice and showcase this on a
regular basis so you're not
describing in your books or
on television some type of fetishized
romanticized
version of survival which i think is
highly highly uh common these days so
perhaps we could start with just
survival fantasy versus survival reality
i'll leave it broad on purpose but
where should we start in terms of
discussing
the common misconceptions of survival or
portrayals of survival versus the
realities yeah i think you set it up as
a
sort of a dichotomy or like a two
mindsets one is
the impulse to run away from the woods
that it's this bad place that you found
yourself stuck in
and you need to get out as quickly as
possible before something terrible
happens to you
the other is and it's sort of my mindset
and it kind of
captures the ethos of
our new book is that it's a place worth
running toward the outdoors nature
wilderness is a place we want to be
it's fun to be there and a few
skill set and knowledge base helps you
do it
fairly risk-free or at least having a
good sense of what the actual risks are
do it safely risk free enjoy it for you
enjoy it for your family so you might
imagine like a lot of survival materials
is kind of like you said
it's like this fantasy thing there's
this fixation on
drinking your piss which is really
really like it's nonsense it doesn't do
you any good to drink your own urine
and you know these like cockamamie ways
in which you would
kill large animals that would never in a
million years work unless you trained
and
studied those approaches every day for
your entire life
which you'd be prevented from doing
because of the regulatory structures
that govern
such practices it's just hogwash and
then there's
people who through passion through
professional discipline
through wanderlust want to be out
in the woods they want to be up in the
mountains they want to be smart
they want to be able to stay a long time
and
that's the information i try to provide
and that's the people i want to speak to
let's just jump into some of
the recommendations that you might have
and we can weave to this in a more
indirect fashion but as we were
discussing
possible points to touch upon in our
conversation beforehand and record
you mentioned a number of things you
mentioned technology and how you can buy
your way out of trouble relatively
easily in certain respects
you referred to something known as
paradoxical undressing which
aside from being the name of my
forthcoming memoir
is is
unbeknownst to me we talked about odds
in other words perceived threats versus
real threats
and much more let's begin just yeah
that one i think of the threats that are
fun to think about
right that are exciting to think about
and the ones that are just
real that no one likes to think about
the first blood threats like carry a
serrated machete into the wilderness
versus other let's begin with
paradoxical undressing
what is paradoxical addressing just to
scratch my own itch because it's stuck
in my head
yeah i first wrote about and got to
thinking about
hypothermia i've come up close to
feeling like oh wow i'm like in the
initial stages of hypothermia
i've had that happen to me a few times
one time in a very pronounced way
it was being in a in a river
in alaska in october with a
dry suit on that had a ruptured
seam and like my dry suit was full of
water and
some of the things that happened in
those and it was kind of this
over the course of 45 minutes to an hour
intense thirst like just this intense
desire to quench my thirst
and being disoriented
realizing that i was very cold realizing
that i didn't have the ambition
to remedy that situation trying to talk
myself
into doing the things that would be
required to get warm again
and then oddly the sensation
that the cold had passed though there
was no plausible explanation
for why i would all of a sudden not be
cold anymore
and in researching this i got to reading
a fair bit about
hypothermia and in addition to some
interesting things like the number one
state for hypothermia deaths is alaska
number three is new mexico which caught
me by surprise
number two i think bounces between
wyoming and montana
but then jumps down south to new mexico
which made people have in their head as
being like a plenty warm place
yeah that's surprising so your body when
in terms of the paradoxical undressing
as you're getting cold your body starts
to
restrict blood flow to your extremities
the blood vessels constrict
that's why you might notice that you
know as you're getting cold your fingers
will turn
white right your toes get cold your
fingers will turn white
your body doesn't want to be pushing all
that blood
out to places where it's getting cooled
i want to add anything here to talk
about like
a lot of animals use
the movement of blood into thin parts of
the body
as a way to shed heat so if you look at
an african elephant
an african elephant has these giant ears
right compare that to a woolly mammoth
an ice age animal the woe of the mammoth
very small ears
willie mammoth lived in these very cold
climates they didn't want to have that
blood out in their ears because
the heat gets sapped out of it an
african elephant very hot place puts a
lot of blood into its ears
to try to cool that blood off it's like
you know running it into a radiator so
to speak
so your body thinking the same way and
as much as we can call it your body
thinking
but your body doesn't want to send blood
out to the extremities where it's
getting cold
it tries to keep things in your core
and keep you know your internal organs
warm that requires a lot of energy
so there's this thing that happens to
hypothermia victims
where they'll find someone who's died of
exposure died of hypothermia their
clothes will be laying all around them
because it requires all that energy to
constrict the blood vessels
eventually they tire you run out of the
energy
to restrain it and all of a sudden your
body allows all that blood back out into
those places
because it's difficult to keep it in as
your energy fades
so that hot blood goes out to these cold
fingers and and goes out toward your
skin
and gives you this sensation of burning
up
some people paradoxically undress to the
point where they start discarding
jewelry
you'll find victims of hypothermia with
a shoe and a sock off a wedding ring off
clothes scattered about but then lying
they're dead
the paradoxical undressing so it starts
to make sense is like
you're dying of being cold but you're
discarding your clothing
it's kind of hair like like spooky it's
just
such a unnerving thought i think too
when i think of people dying of exposure
it wasn't too long ago not far from
where i am right now
where an ice fisherman
fell through the ice and
just speaking of spooky scenes an ice
fisherman
falls through the ice and there's no
snow on the ice and imagine how slick
wet ice is
like imagine trying to pick an ice cube
up out of a drink right
when ice is wet what it's like to hold
on to you try to squeeze it it just pops
out of your hand
there's no snow on the ice and he goes
through the ice and because he's punched
to the ice and he's splashing around
water is getting up on the ice so
there's nothing to grab onto
you had mentioned like you can buy your
way out of a lot of bad situations
through preparation but you know they
make a device for this these little ice
picks you just wear around your neck
he doesn't have a set of these someone
finds him a couple days later
frozen to death up to his
armpits in a hole in the ice
with one of his boots laid up on the ice
just perched there dying of
cold man is a real thing
dying of exposure is a real thing and
just the mental images that come
up from it are kind of more
ghastly than some of the more
fantastical ways that we
imagine ourselves getting injured in the
woods
being like fixated on grizzly bears and
mountain lions and such let's talk about
exposure for a second i remember i was
told
many years ago this i'm sure it's just a
convenient
mnemonic device but someone said to me
you can go three weeks without food
three days without water three hours
without some type of
protection in really extreme conditions
environmentally speaking right something
like that yeah that threes thing
i've heard it described in various ways
three weeks food
three days water and then it'll be three
whatever without air
say
but yeah i i i'm familiar with the thing
and i've and i've
heard it used a handful of ways what are
some of the ways
that you can buy your way
into some margin of safety maybe you
don't eliminate risk entirely
but what are some of the easy purchases
that would go into a basic kit of some
type doesn't have to be even basic but
just
some of these specific purchases that
are easy ways
to remove a lot or mitigate a lot of
risk like you mentioned the
ice picks that hang around the neck yeah
for someone who's doing a lot on ice
right yeah so those ice picks are common
for
not common they should be way more
common among ice fishermen but ice
fishermen are the ones who
use them and they're made they're
generally manufactured by companies that
make fishing equipment if that speaks to
who it is but it's like these little
imagine a ice pick inside a retractable
sleeve
so there's nothing sharp sticking out
but the minute you jab it down
you know the sleeve retracts on a spring
and the ice pick goes into the ground
or into the ice and it's just a thing
it's like an epipen for getting out of
yeah exactly and you can be on the
slickest ice in the world lice you could
never stand up on you could take the
slickest ice in the world
put water on it lay down
take that pick and just drag yourself
all over the place with that pick
when i was mentioning to you just in
private conversation
earlier i was mentioning you buying your
way out
i'm reminded of a thing that if you're
familiar with john mcphee who wrote
that pulitzer prize-winning trilogy
coming into the country
no no his geology his geology oh yeah so
he wrote this
pulitzer prize trilogy that it came out
as like basin and range
whatever it's annals of the former world
so it's
three massive books all combined
together into annals of the former world
now remember that
within annals of the former world john
mcphee says
if i was gonna sum this book up in one
sentence
it would be that i'm trying to capture
what he says without
this is not an exact quote he says if i
was gonna sum this book up in one
sentence
it would be that the peak of mount
everest
is marine limestone if i was gonna sum
up
the wilderness skills and survival book
that
we just finished i would say on x
in reach and i'll tell you what these
two things are
on x is a mapping service there are many
i like on x and and just for full
clarity i also
you know work closely with the folks at
onyx so bear that in mind but
let me continue there's a reason i do
that it's a mapping device that you use
on your phone and there are other ones
there's like
gaia and a handful other ones um you can
i'm not sure if
google earth has download function quite
like onx does but
it's a mapping service that you can
download maps on your phone you can
download
aerial imagery topographical maps
and hybrid maps so it's aerial imagery
with topographical line
overlays and you can download maps of
areas you're going to
that are highly detailed that are you
know five miles wide
and 10 miles wide and then lower detail
lower resolution maps that are 100 miles
wide
what it does is your phone has a
built-in gps function
that does not require a sell signal
so if you're using an iphone and you're
going into
you're going to some area for whatever
reason you're going there for work
you're going there for pleasure you're
going back country skiing
you're going on a hike with your family
in
yellowstone national park your
whatever whatever you're doing you're on
a rafting trip
you're doing a afternoon hike into a
little area you've never been into
before
you can go online and download a map and
then even when you have no sell signal
all you need to do is turn on your phone
put it on airplane mode you now have two
or three days
worth of battery because you're on
airplane mode
and there's a blue dot that shows you
where you are
when you aim your phone in any direction
and hit a button it shows you
what direction your phone is pointing
relative to your map
so at any time you should be if you take
the early pre-game preparation
the idea of getting lost is almost
becoming
an obsolete notion or you have to almost
self-select to be lost
by not taking preparations of course
things can happen to phones people lose
phones they drop in water i have all
this kind of stuff has happened
but they they destroy them in a puddle
of mosquito repellent you can you can
do once in a pool of deep but
that's why i was saying onyx in reach
because
there's also a device that's i don't
know
a third the size of a phone called an in
reach device
some people come spot devices or in
reach devices what it is is it allows
you to
send text messages
through satellite so you can take an
inreach device
and no matter where you are you know on
the face of the earth
if you have a line of sight to the sky
you can save addresses in your inreach
you can take your inreach and set it so
that
it's sending pre-programmed messages
every day
saying you can type your message ahead
of time hit a button that sends a
message says i'm okay
but you can also hold down a button that
says sos
and it's satellite driven and the
batteries last for days
so in talking about like buying your way
out there are just
steps now that you can take to
if you're the kind of person who takes
preparation seriously there are steps
you can take that really reduce
a lot of the risk there are still things
that can happen to you right
you still i joked about it earlier but
yeah man you could get
mauled by a bear the bear doesn't give a
[ __ ] about the fact that
you have any of these technological
devices but
if you're still able to crawl around is
pretty nice
to be able to hold a button down and
get help and so these are all things
that i spent a great deal of time on in
the book
because it's not trying to treat
survival like you've survived a plane
crash and you have a large
bowie knife you know and you're stuck on
an island
it doesn't start with that mentality it
starts with the mentality it starts with
the reality
that the vast majority of trouble that
people get in outdoors
is somewhat willful
we do things we go places we take drives
during inclement weather
we decide to go on a route through the
hills when we're driving
that we've never been on and we don't
know the road conditions
and your car gets stuck and then you
wait there two days and no one comes and
you're like
screw this i'm walking out of here but
you don't quite know
what to do or your car is not loaded
properly that's how people get in
trouble
it isn't shipwrecks and plane crashes
though those things do happen but
pondering those and fantasizing about
those
throws off people's ability to actually
like think and behave properly
and these little technological
preparations are just things you can do
that just make you breathe easy
and allow you to go into wild places and
do what it was that you intended to do
just to be like successful and be
impactful
and pursue whatever goals you have
whether it's finding a mushroom or
bagging a peak
without feeling as though you've entered
a survival situation
i just want to comment on a few things
that you've said so number one
totally sort of unbeknownst to me
or i should say rather i had no
pre-existing awareness that you used
onyx hunt
i also ended up using onyx and hev for
the last
five months and i should just mention to
people that if you search for it on the
app store i think it will show up as on
x hunt but the hunting certainly is one
application but it's not a
requirement my realtor uses yeah yeah
okay so this is
this is this is actually this is related
to my point so i was
exploring the wilderness in new england
and during covet lockdown and
i wanted to know a number of things i
wanted to be able to track my
own movement so that i could retrace my
steps which
onyx allows you to do i wanted the
offline maps which you mentioned
i also wanted the ability to know where
property boundaries were so that i
wouldn't end up
wandering right up to somebody's house
or into someone's property that would
get me into trouble
so i was able to overlay the
property information which is just
fascinating i've never
quite experienced anything like it so on
x i'll second that and then the
inreach i'm not sure if more brands make
it but i used a garmin inreach when i
was in
south america at one point and the
pre-programming with the texts
is i think like a key step pre-departure
because they are they can be a little
unwieldy for actually typing out
messages so if you are in an sos
situation you want to have your contacts
and messages pre-programmed okay let me
give you some hot let me give you some
hot tips about that when you're done
here
yeah fire away i'm done oh
there is a iphone
app called i'm gonna give you the right
name so i'm looking for it i'm actually
looking for it on my phone right now
there's an iphone app called garmin
earth mate
and garmin earth mate pairs with your
inreach device
over bluetooth oh god you're about to
this is the solution that i didn't know
anything you just have at it man
there's an important thing to remember
though here then you just have ad then
you're just you're just flying it
then you this one then you can send out
novellas yeah
dude yeah and i think you're you know
there's a there's a limit it's more than
a twitter message but
and then you gotta go to number two but
the other thing to keep in mind
when you're using it you're using
satellite you can
text someone who has
cell service someone with cell service
can text you
at your inreach number but if you're in
a remote area
using your inreach address trying to
contact
say your buddy who's two miles away at
camp
you need to know their in-reach address
so it can communicate like let's say i
go to
text my wife and i know that she's at
home and has cell service i can text her
directly to her number
that she can then reply but she's
replying to my in reach number which is
independent from my normal phone number
a lot of people mess this up because you
could go like let's say you go down to
south america no one's got cell service
if you don't communicate with your
travel mates like hey man
what is your crazy ass sounding in reach
address
you can't send each other messages so
you have to build an address book
ahead of time or else you are in a
situation
of texting someone back in the us who
has cell service
and they're like texting around we were
doing this year day i was trying to i
could see a person
and i'm trying to send him an in-reach
message but instead i'm in reaching his
wife
does she if she can and she's like was
everybody okay i'm like
yeah i'm looking at your husband he's
fine i just want to send him a message
so you gotta do a little bit of you know
take five minutes
to make sure that everybody's
communicating everybody's
in reach address in the process of
separating more
fact from fiction or really just
pointing out essentials versus
non-essentials
as you mentioned little things can be
really costly
right and a lot of the mistakes that end
up in disaster are not
of the outdoor thriller action movie
variety they would make the most boring
television show in the world right it's
like oh [ __ ] i forgot the batteries in
my headlamp
and then i die or something stupid
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the four
hour body this is more than ten years
ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula
on the market it has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex
probiotics and prebiotics for gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases if i miss anything
i'm not aware of
of course i focus on nutrient-dense
meals to begin with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around and right now
athletic greens is giving my audience
that's you guys
a special offer on top of their
all-in-one formula which is a free
vitamin d supplement with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so particularly in the
winter months adding a vitamin d
supplement to your daily routine is a
great option for additional immune
support
so make an investment in your health
today and try the ultimate all-in-one
wellness bundle
support your immunity gut health and
energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com tim you'll receive up
to a year's supply of vitamin d for free
with your first subscription purchase
again that's
athleticgreens.com tim
what are some of the essentials that you
routinely use that listeners
may not find obvious or
may not grok the subtleties of right you
mentioned like the bowie knife i think a
lot of
unseasoned outdoors
men or women are inclined to get these
big honkin
you know jump off a ravine and kill a
grizzly uh
in an action movie knives as one example
but what are some of the essential
pieces of gear that you would have in
your kit
yeah i i'd like to talk for a minute
just about like
the kit you know which is something
spent a lot of time on the book
explaining how to assemble and how to
make it
adaptable and versatile to get a sense
a somewhat widely available product
there's a there's a thing called a or
backcountry organizer various companies
make different
ones that are various heavy-duty fabrics
but i've long been a fan of a thing
called the or
backcountry organizer and it's a it'd be
like a slightly flattened
pretty big coffee mug size okay
it's this little bag it's got a bunch of
zippered pouches in it
and me the folks i hang out with
we all have like a kit that we call it a
kit like it's like your
essentials and a lot of us assemble ours
in one of these
in one of these little bags i put that
thing
i take it virtually everywhere i go
i don't mean to my office but if my fam
we go to for instance
we go to baja every year for winter
vacation to go spearfishing
and just messing around spending family
time together
i always pack it because in it i have
like all the things that i know i might
need
regardless of the situation if i had a
kit and i go on a day hike
if i'm just going you know for an hour
hike
up a hill with the dog and the kids
i bring my kit now when i say my kit i
would say a survival kit i would say
it's a first aid kit but it's
all of those things and more
in it i keep several single-sized
ibuprofen tablets acetaminophen tablets
benadryl okay various medications
i bring i have like one or two things a
day quill and nyquil in there
antihistamine things like single serving
packs very very small
in there i also keep two 25 foot length
dyneema cords that are very thin they're
like three or four mil
chords that i keep in dyneema chords are
like it's like
it's a material chord yeah it's like a
souped up it's a it's a souped-up strong
lightweight paracord there's nothing
wrong with paracord like paracord like
660 cord like 600 pound cord
stuff's great man i use it all the time
but for my things i like to keep it very
small
as small as possible i use that stuff
i keep a small thing of dental floss
and tape to it is a heavy duty needle
that can be used to sew up clothing and
stuff i keep that in there at all times
i have a small sharpener
there's a small knife in there there's a
small backup headlamp in there that's
about the size of the end of your thumb
that burns on a coin battery and has a
retractable
little head strap i also put my primary
flashlight
in there as well i have
a basic first aid kit assembled inside a
plastic envelope
that includes a variety of bandages
alcohol swabs antibiotic ointment
a very small tourniquet other items like
that
i keep a chew tin a tobacco tin
full of cotton balls that have been
rubbed in like thoroughly rubbed in with
petroleum jelly or vaseline which are
phenomenal fire starters
the reason i use vaseline rubbed into
cotton balls stuffed inside a chew tin
is because one vaseline is also helpful
for chapped lips
chaff skin can be helpful for
alleviating pain from blisters
the primary reason is that the tsa
agents
at the airport i travel a lot they will
pull
fire starting devices like incendiary
devices or fires or
uh not incendiary what's the word i'm
looking for tim like um
accelerants fire accelerant accelerants
yeah they will pull
accelerants from your bag and find you
there's no problem with having some
vaseline in your bag
now a a cotton a cotton ball rubbed with
vaseline
burns it's a
great fire starter uh it can get wet it
doesn't mess it up
and tsa guys never steal it so it's just
always in your bag
i keep a small multi-tool i have a
multi-tool
that allows for a certain bit adapter so
i'm able to keep some basic screwdriver
bits
that fit various things that i own and
use
in there i hunt a lot so i have archery
stuff
firearm stuff little screws and bits i
like to have on hand
i keep those in my organizer and
it's filled out like that two small
lighters
tape med tape when i say that it's
adaptable as let's say i'm spending some
time up in southeast alaska
there are places in southeast alaska
that get
13 feet of precipitation annually
okay where i'm staying where i am right
now it gets 20 inches of precipitation
and yeah
let me just put this perspective for a
second
yeah let me just put this in perspective
for folks so yesterday
i was looking at historic
ski reports and precipitation for taos
new mexico this is a place
famous for skiing and i was looking at
the end of november to mid december and
it was an average of
something like point eight to one and a
half ski days per week
that's not a lot of snow and this is a
place that ultimately is well known for
skiing
so then you imagine the amount
of precipitation you're describing that
is a ton of
precipitation yeah oftentimes
here's here's a survival like a survival
trope
is that you know that you're gonna
be in an environment like this and
fashion a fire drill
like a little fire bow and start a fire
or
that you're gonna take like a flint and
steel and start a fire or you're gonna
take a hatch into rock
and start a fire there are people on the
planet
including like the native alaskans who
lived in that place
and you know grew up there feeling as
though they had
excellent equipment and they used
equipment that their grandfathers had
used
and their fathers and mothers before
them and and it was just like a part of
life and they knew how to use it
right there are people on the planet who
can do that but i'm gonna say that when
i'm talking to you i'm talking to the
collective you out there
you are not going to go to a place that
gets 13 feet of rain a year
and start a fire just the the
99.9 percent of you are not going to go
there
and start a fire using anything
other than matches or a lighter you're
just not
it is so hard it's so hard
so hard so hard yeah so when i'm going
to a place like this
i will have i have a drawer in my garage
full of kits that go within my kit
okay and i have my super hard to start
a fireplace bag
that goes into my kit i have a you know
other little
envelopes that i will stick in there i
have a little envelope that has
some survival snares
and some very basic fishing equipment
if i was going to an area like an
extremely remote area in alaska
i might for peace of mind
grab that little like enhanced food
acquisition
envelope just to give me peace of mind
that
in the event of there being a grounding
of aircraft or something else
that prevented a timely pickup a timely
pre-arranged pickup
that i would have extra stuff and in
those situations my
kit might blossom now you might think
like what are the odds of that well
after september 11th so on september 11
there were people in backcountry canada
and backcountry alaska who had arranged
to be picked up at airstrips
people out hunting could be that they're
out prospecting gold mining whatever the
hell they're doing
we're waiting at airstrips to be picked
up and the one thing no matter where you
are in alaska man
most days sometimes all day you hear
aircraft
aircraft is their car in bush alaska
you wake up one day you don't have news
you don't know what's going on
but you know that the skies are quiet
nothing flies you're supposed to be
getting picked up
no one shows up it's as though the world
ended and you don't know what happened
there was another occurrence in alaska
i believe this occurred in the 80s where
there was a big volcanic
eruption that put a lot of ash in the
air and they resumed flying
shortly after but a jet's coming in
and this ash gets picked up in the
engines and turns to a sort of glassy
like substance and blinks out all four
engines
eventually this stuff like shatters out
somehow and they're able to get a couple
engines re-lit
and they land but they grounded aircraft
for a long time
i had a friend he was out at a remote
wilderness camp
taking care of some horses and he got
stuck for weeks
no supplies nothing flying had no idea
what was going on
he ran out of food and had a salt lick
for a horse like a salt block
he would eat porcupines and go out with
a pocket knife and scrape salt off a
salt block in order to get some salt to
put on the porcupine meat that sounds
terrible it's like a thing
then you're you enter the fantastic but
think about the people i'm talking about
these people aren't people that fell out
of an airplane they're people that went
willfully into a situation
where if you do good risk assessment
and you think about what are the
problems that would actually happen to
go into a very remote area of alaska or
canada whatever
frank church in idaho i don't know like
a remote area
and you're flying in anyone that does
any amount of homework can realize now
and then you simply don't get picked up
because of weather because of a
terror attack on the east coast of
the united states because of a volcano
on the alaska peninsula or the aleutians
so that's the thing that we're thinking
about often
is okay in our risk assessment what's
the real problem that might occur
i would say high on my list of [ __ ] that
might occur would be that we're going to
sit here for three or four days
yeah and are we prepared for that
because that could be a little miserable
and i want to also emphasize for folks
who are
listening that i consider you
no one bats a thousand but i consider
you an expert
in risk mitigation
with simple and elegant
insurance countermeasures if that makes
any sense it's a very wordy way to put
it
i understand i i appreciate the
sentiment i understand what you're
talking about
yeah because there are a lot of let's
just say
we're in the perfect era right now with
covid sort of
mad max scenario planning where people
are
thinking where it's going to be on the
road by cory mccarthy and
people are going to be trying to eat my
kids and i'm going to stockpile
silver coins and like shave off gold
bars to get tampons with the guy in the
back of the 7-eleven
and it comes down to probabilities
sort of historical likelihood and the
cost
of the intervention right so i've never
had
a significant fire of any type in my
kitchen nonetheless i have
a let's call it 20 or 30 dollar
fire extinguisher that sits there
gathering dust because it's cheap
it's easy to use and if you need it you
want to have it
yeah on the other hand you might have
let's just say
using a bow drill to start a fire which
i've practiced
doing and i have got to the point where
i could do it
very infrequently successfully and that
took a lot of work
but to rely on that to get to the point
where i would feel comfortable relying
on that
that becomes my new sport like that's
like learning
that's kind of what i'm saying is like
people that can start a fire with a bow
drill
are people that start fires with bow
drills
because they they do it recreationally
they practice right they live with it
and practice it yeah
just to dig into the backcountry
organizer
and that i would just again to perhaps
restate the obvious
is taking something that is half the
size
of the say water
container you might take with you it's
smaller than that it's smaller than an
algae bottle
right so this is we're not talking about
a lot of inconvenience here
is the or backcountry organizer just the
container or does it come
pre-loaded with a lot of these items no
man it's just a container
i have and there are there are other
ones there are other companies that make
similar products under you know
the difference tends to be weight and
durability you know they're susceptible
to tear the seams give out but it's it's
lightweight there are other companies
that make
you know fhf make certain organizers
that are pretty heavy duty they're great
that one is just a very lightweight one
what is your preferred
multi-tool do you remember what you
carry yeah
i i use a leather man i like the wave
a lot it's heavy i got friends that
really don't like them
i'll tell you what i like on them i like
a regular blade
and we know we've been joking about big
ass
you know rambo knives and bowie knives
and stuff
i've done a lot of everything that you
would need to do with a knife
and there are cases where it would be
great if you had some giant machete type
knife
but generally for the kinds of things
we're talking about
like keeping yourself out of trouble
handling basic repairs
the the knife on a multi-tool is a good
backup to also having you know
i carry like a very high quality very
lightweight
pocket knife called a bug out but i have
a multi tool with me
yeah it's very lightweight very sharp
you get in a variety of ways you don't
even know it's there it's a good knife
so the leatherman i like one that has a
saw on it
like a wood saw bone saw i like one that
has a serrated blade
for doing work that would very quickly
dull your normal blade
i like it to have a normal blade you
know two or three inch blade
on it and i really like it to have a
pair of needle nose pliers
i use those things all the time in the
book we provide lists of all this kind
of equipment but in my kit
i carry this little a little sliver
remover
it's like nothing it's you know it's
earlier i mentioned something being the
size of your
the end of your thumb this is like a
couple thumbnails it's like a sliver
remover paired
tweezers which is invaluable especially
in areas of the
south and southwest for just the
annoyance of getting junk stuck in your
skin which can drive you crazy
but i also use the needle nose pliers
for all kinds of stuff we've used needle
nose pliers for
everything from like pulling porcupine
quills out of dogs
fixing ingrown toenails repairing
clothes fixing firearms
it's like i can do anything with a pair
of needle nose man um
i like that to be on there and then a
number two phillips bit
a flathead screwdriver of a fairly
universal size
if i actually wound up in some situation
where i was stuck out in the woods for a
week
and tell let's i'm going to return to my
point but i just want to make something
clear
for a living for a long time
i travel to the remotest places out
there
i did it as a writer i've done it for a
decade
doing television magazine work and such
like
i go to really remote places i go to the
places where people imagine troubling
occurred
and i travel with a crew of
highly adept very skilled individuals
someone might say like but you've never
had to like live out for a month with no
food or anything i'm like
that's kind of the point to have done
the things that
we've done and figured out the ways in
which we like
avoid trouble avoid disaster
get what we need to get done done that's
the survival i'm talking about
and if i knew i was gonna be stranded
out somewhere like oh
man i really want to have a multi-tool
but i just
use a multi-tool in living my life
that's why like a big part of the title
i think that
in struggling with it would be like the
guide to survival i'm like okay my head
just goes to fantasyland
wilderness skills and survival be like
wilderness skills is just like the doing
how to be out and do things and yeah man
i have seen everything from outboard
engines to generators to cars to human
beings
repaired with a multi-tool by someone
who
kind of understands how to do things i
always have a multi-tool
in the car i will since we since we
invoked the name of the tsa earlier i
will
just mention to folks that i've had to
sacrifice
quite a few multi-tools and those are
sad moments the multi-tool stealing his
sons [ __ ] on the planet
god bless my god do they take some
multi-tools i understand
yeah brutal can't go on a plane with a
with a knife and it's like now and then
you're standing there and you're in line
and also they pull your bag and you're
just like oh
that's another one not another one
this is so bad we actually like standing
in line now we
actually like like if i'm with you know
buddies of mine or guys i work with
it's like a common thing you know you'd
be like oh you got your passport you'd
be like
dude knives knives knives you know
right got it thanks that's a sinking
feeling
i haven't looked into it but somehow
they auction or sell
oh the confiscated items like buck i
think you buy like them by the bucket i
don't know i i i i want to look into it
i think they like somehow you know they
all go somewhere
the cash can airport in alaska this is
one of my favorite things on the
on the planet is in in ketchikan as
you're waiting in line for security they
have a display case of things that have
been confiscated
at the ketchikan airport in this display
case
is a brass knuckles
dagger so it's
brass knuckles with an 8-inch
double-bladed dagger
coming out of it so which makes me feel
a lot better about the multi-tools i've
lost because someone who thought that
that would be a thing to pack along
on a trip i just would love to have
vanilla have a brief interview with with
presumably that gentleman maybe as a
woman but presumably the gentleman who
had the brass knuckles dagger
at the ketchikan airport and lost it and
they're like the kind of brass knuckles
that has the pointy knuckles like the
like
oh yeah they would like perforate your
skin for you
it's the greatest let's talk about water
what
are your recommendations for how to
think about procuring or purifying water
that could that could be an extension of
kit and then we back into
finding and filtering but how would you
suggest people
think about that would love to so in
laying out like in a lot of the chapters
in the book we lay out like the food
chapter
the water chapters laid out this way
navigation is laid out this way
it starts out like the chapters always
start out like perfect world
right so in water be like perfect world
here's how many gallons a person's gonna
use a day
for intake meaning to make food um
you know if you're using freeze-dried
food whatever on on camping trips or
outings work outings whatever
to make food and drinks so how what's
the quantity of water that'll actually
go into your body
and then there's the quantity of water
per day
with some you know climatic variations
depending on where you are in the world
that with intake so physical intake and
then basic cleaning and then water for
if you're doing some amount of bathing
and like all these water quantities that
you bring with you in jugs right so you
fill a jug off of garden hose
loading your camper loading your truck
and that's where you are you just live
off of jugged water which is great do it
all the time car camping water
but then the chat would go through like
worse worse worse worse worse worse
and then end kind of on oh [ __ ] so
starting out with that idea of water
moving into
the idea of sourcing water so sourcing
water
where you have the proper equipment to
do so and then it moves into sourcing
water where you do not have the proper
equipment to do so and then basically
down to sourcing water you have
you have [ __ ] with you have nothing you
got to figure everything out including a
container
but for real world use i spend most of
my time
when i'm out with equipment sourcing
water on site with some basic equipment
that enables
me to do so and i feel that like a good
universal water kit for any kind of
overnighting trips or trips that could
turn into overnighting
use a nalgene bottle or it doesn't need
to be nalgene
we use analogy now it's like a brand
name they make scientific containers and
equipment and beakers and stuff but
they've become
a real dominant force in like screw top
bottles the gray bottles are very
durable
you can freeze stuff in them it doesn't
crack them they're great there's a
hundred companies that make them
a nalgene bottle and then we use a thing
we call a drum
or a dromedary which is a collapsible
water bottle you can get various things
like liter
two liter maybe 1.5 liter and when
they're empty
it's nothing it's like imagine an empty
duty somewhat heavy duty little shopping
bag
and you put in the bottom of your pack
you don't even know it's there but
when it's full it's great it's a good
source of water so carry an algine
carry a drum in my kit that i mentioned
earlier i always carry
water purification tablets okay in
single serving packs so it's these
little foil packs in each of those foil
packs there's one or two tablets in it
you put those towels in water iodine or
what is yeah there's iodine there's some
diff there's some different ones that
have different active ingredients but
yeah
iodine tablets there's other i get into
the other compounds but there's
it's all iodine-like but there are some
different active ingredients in
different tablets
um and then they might argue amongst
themselves about which has the worst or
better aftertaste
there are also neutralizers you can add
like if you if you hate that taste that
comes from water purification tablets
there are neutralizing tablets that
diminish that taste
and you can get them in single serving
packs so i keep those in my kit no
matter what no matter where i go i have
those in my kit
so i have those with me and i also
lately well not even lately for years
now
i have used what's called a steripen
with
great results i love them it's a
uv light wand imagine a lightsaber
that's maybe five inches long
um it runs on a cr123 battery
you put it in there and it can purify
a quart of water in 90 seconds
using a uv light wand that you just
swirl around
in the water a couple complications with
this is like if the water is too
turbid so if it's like an incredibly
muddy water you would need to double
dose it or triple dose it
because of light penetration through the
water
a problem you might encounter this is
all stuff we cover like a problem you
might encounter is that
scooping water up can be hard like if
you're just trying to get water out of
wet moss
you know and you can press a hand down
and like get a little bit of water in
your palm
it can be an arduous task i usually
carry a small plastic camp cup with me
anyways for drinking coffee and stuff in
the morning
you can use uh and the camp cup is a
little bit flexible
so you can force this thing into little
crevices like if you have a cliff face
with some water just sort of like
running down and that's the only water
you can find
you can kind of mash this cup up against
the cliff face
and slowly get dripping water into the
cup
and use that to fill that rigid mouth
nalgene and eventually get that thing
full and then wand it
with a steripen to purify it where you
might have a problem is if everything's
frozen you can't steer your pen
ice but when you're using snowmelt
all you need is a small stove and you
can run off snowmelt
it's exhaustive on fuel and that's
something we get into as well is like
the yield on snow is surprisingly low it
takes a lot of
energy fire fuel whatever it takes a lot
of energy to melt snow on the water but
it's like a thing we cover
but if you get that basic thing down and
again this is like standard operating
procedure
of water bottle dromedary and the
dromedary bag
i carry a two-liter dromedary bag i just
keep in the bottom of a pack
you can fill that at a source and then
carry it with you and purify it as you
use it
you can get two fills and dump it into
your
bottle purify it with a steripen and
you're pretty bulletproof man with that
setup as long as you can find
some source of surface water and we
explain a lot of tricks of the trade
and how to locate surface water when you
don't have the obvious
locations of creeks and ponds and stuff
but
i'll point out here a real real risk
and this is not a fun risk but a real
real risk
waterborne pathogens are a problem
i have been sick several times from
waterborne pathogens
it is miserable you can get so sick that
it's debilitating
it can just be bad or it can be bad bad
so you cannot afford to be careless
drinking surface water and
people make a lot of mistakes of seeing
some water they feel is like coming out
of some
little seep and they think oh it must be
fine because this is the source
when in fact if they walk 10 yards
uphill they'd find like an elk wallow
where they're [ __ ] and pissing and
rolling around in the mud
and it's not adequately filtered from
having passed through that mucky ground
and you can get sick waterborne
pathogens
they're like part of this whole suite of
the little things that kill
and that is the thing with water more
than bears more
mountain lions waterborne pathogens are
are a [ __ ] do you also carry
a smaller
purification device that is pumped
something like
catadyne i don't know if that's not
correctly
i do not anymore i personally
a lot of people like them i personally
had a lot of trouble
with things with ceramic filters and
other filters where
it's wet from use and it freezes they
get plugged up i've just had a lot of
hassle on river trips
on river like rafting canoe trips and
stuff where you just you know
like you just have water because you're
floating down the damn river right you
know you're gonna have plenty of water
around
we will use those gravity fed
drip bags that hold a few gallons of
water
you just scoop it up in the river and
you hang it from a tree limb
and there's a gravity fed filter on
there
we will use those if we know that
conditions are going to be good like
summertime conditions
where you're it's not going to be
freezing at night
crippling your filter you're going to
have a pretty good source of water
that's not going to be overly muddy
and it just kind of like when times are
good it's a it's a good device
but the pumps know i've not i don't like
them
on glacial rivers with the glacial till
it's just
a lot of headache i'm sure there are
people that know what they're talking
about and they like them and there might
be people who
dislike uv light pens for various
reasons because if you're traveling
overseas like if you're traveling in
africa
you need to have a purification system
and you always need to check to make
sure what you're using how you're using
it
you're going to want a purification
system that also can handle viruses
if you were in the u.s okay if you're
hanging out in the us
out doing like camping type activities
and you're not like um you're not around
a lot of human contamination but you're
out in like you know
in the woods in the mountains whatever
like somewhat like halfway pristine
environments
you don't need to worry about viruses
you're mostly talking about really big
things giardia
cryptosporidia large things that are
easy to filter out
so if you're going on a backpacking trip
in the developing world somewhere
um and you're going to be dealing with
areas that have human
potentially human waste in the water we
explain all this stuff too in the book
but
human waste in the water you need you're
gonna practice a different
purification system and you might even
do something like a dual purification
system
where you have things again from human
contamination
but the primary focus here that i'm
talking about is like is classic like
backpack and hiking wilderness outings
what are some
items that people should have
in their cars i'm wondering if there's
anything that people might not have
thought of and i'd love to hear your
opinion on
what some people call space blankets or
mylar blankets these emergency blankets
are they
is there helpfulness overestimated
underestimated
but generally things that people might
want to consider in their car right
because i have
uh people have get themselves into
trouble in all sorts of places
including spots where they might not
expect to get into trouble like north of
say san francisco going to tahoe and
underestimating the amount of snowfall
and realizing that they don't have
chains sure but perhaps they've driven
already three hours in traffic and
they're like
[ __ ] it yolo i'm going skiing
and then lo and behold uh oh i mean
that's mistake number one people die
every year people die every year in
stranded vehicles in this country
talking about cars we start getting into
we're talking about like you know
like prepper land and i'll point out
that i'm uh in my car
and at home i'm a sort of unintentional
or
accidental prepper where
i do a lot of camping so i have like a
lot of freeze-dried food
i buy a lot of it i keep it in bins in
my garage
so that when i'm going somewhere i have
a lot of and i also just like also
take us just i like to have it on hand
i'm going to use it anyways
it's in my garage so i have enough
freeze-dried food
to because i bought it for one thing in
mind
it also serves the purpose where i have
enough freeze-dried food to keep my
family up and running for quite a long
time
on freeze-dried food we have all kinds
of you know we camp lots we have all
kinds of camp stoves
alternate fuel sources water
purification equipment that i own
through camping
i'm a firearm owner i keep
you know for that purpose i keep quite a
bit of ammunition on hand
the one thing i do like the one thing i
do that's like totally prepper-like
and this came from time i spent living
in seattle where you have you're in a
very seismic
seismically active area and also you
have volcanic activity
and things we kept treated water
in a closet so in my crawl space i do
keep a bunch of jugs
of water that i put long-term treatment
like a chlorine type substance that you
can put in there for long-term treatment
that's the one thing i do that doesn't
have camping ramifications that i'll
point out
i own those big ass jugs because we use
them for water transport while camping
i extend the same kind of mentality to
my personal vehicle
because you know we do a lot of
adventuring i live in the northern
rockies
climate here can be crazy road
conditioning is gonna be crazy
so i'm gonna give you like a pretty
extreme version of like the kinds of
things i keep in my car
i keep a patch kit i also i drive a
truck
i have an f-150 the back seats lift up
you can put all kinds of stuff under
there
i have a decked toolbox in the back of
my truck so i just can keep
various things around but i keep a spot
battery powered spotlight
i have a battery powered air pump i have
a patch kit
i keep an extra head lamp might sound
funny but i keep toothbrush and
toothpaste in there
i keep uh glow sticks in the glove box
that could you know those brake glow
sticks that ravers use
just you use them if you're if your
vehicle is stopped along the side of the
road you can put out glow sticks so that
in a snowstorm or dark conditions people
could see it
i keep a military e-tool like a folding
what it's a folding shovel
like a military folding shovel not all
etools are created equal i got
i got mine from uh a serviceman who
was like no dude you have to have the
right e-tool and he went and got me the
right e-tool a very heavy-duty e-tool
it's a folding a folding saw
i'm sorry a folding shovel when there's
snow on the ground i put in a big
aluminum scoop shovel with a d
handle in the back of my truck i have
two insulated ponchos so they're
basically like sleeping bags with a hole
that you can put over them because i
have young kids so i keep my insulated
ponchos in my truck
i have a food stash in my deck system
like one of the boxes is just full of
granola bars and stuff
which i also use for my kids all the
time because if anyone has kids they
know they're always
like whining about wanting food and i
just feed them out of that box
in the summer months i keep watering
there but it freezes and breaks the
containers in the winter so i pull them
out
and then i have like a basic tool kit so
things i need to
to do repairs i keep some
garbage bags and things in there candles
are great because if you
are in a car in the winter and for
whatever reason you're stranded
and you're running a camp stove say
in your car you can kill yourself from
carbon monoxide
poisoning you do not want to burn fossil
fuels
in a car it is a very quick way
especially if there's a risk of you
falling asleep
it's a death sentence man if you fall
asleep in a car
burning a fossil fuel isopropyl whatever
you know gasoline
white gas you're in trouble man you will
kill yourself so candles
you can bring up the mean temperature in
a car by several degrees
beyond several to a substantial level of
warmth by burning candles in your car
um never realize that oh yeah and then
even like an alcohol stove that people
use on sale bowls people use alcohol
stoves on small sailboats for the same
thing so you can run it without getting
carbon monoxide poisoning
you could have a small seven dollar
alcohol stove
and a little pint bottle full of alcohol
and
heat a car to t-shirt warmth with an
alcohol stove
and you don't need to worry about
killing yourself from carbon monoxide
poisoning
there's still a fire risk but you can
sit in your car and hang out it doesn't
need to be running you can be out of gas
you can have a dead engine
and keep warm and then finally i also
keep a thick wool blanket
that i just roll up and put a strap on
i know a lot of guys will just have a
tote you know
like just you go to walmart whatever and
buy like a plastic tote of an
appropriate size
put all this stuff we have lists in the
book of all this like what what's
minimum maximum like you know best
recommendations make a tote
and if you're just around town going
back and forth to work don't worry about
it
if you go driving three hours to go you
know visit relatives for the
christmas holiday throw the tote in the
back and in that tote
is all the [ __ ] you would ever need to
be more than comfortable
people might laugh you know oh you're a
little goofy oh you're a prepper
was this mad max it's like i like to
just feel at ease and prepared
the other day we were coming back from a
hunting trip my kid pointed out he's 10
years old and he pointed out the thing i
like about our truck
is that we have all the stuff we need
and i was like
uh glo you know glowed with pride upon
hearing that um the
even the sense of the sense of ease
and comfort that my kid got no he had
whatever a headache and i gave him
something for it anyways
a sense of ease and comfort that he got
of feeling like we're on top of
it you know we're not we're our own
people
we got our [ __ ] figured out our system's
dialed
yeah and it's there's it's also
a different breed
of preparation compared to like putting
on a ghillie suit every saturday and
climbing into a spider hole in your
backyard
yeah right it's this is this is just
i mean a lot of these things
particularly i want to
underscore the water supplies the backup
water supplies
for me is cheap cheap insurance that is
kind of one and done
i mean perhaps you replace it every once
in a while but
i'll give an example here i have a
garage with
a significant amount of
potable water because i want to say a
year and a half ago two years ago and
austin texas is this first world
incredibly developed city
incredible medical support and
facilities
this is a top-tier city within the us as
far as livability and everything else
and at one point they had flooding this
happened so there was an
incredible torrential downpour
for a day or two and it overwhelmed the
municipal water treatment plants and
there was a
uh a boil warning for the entire city
all like
human fecal matter into the municipal
water supply that's right so
you could not drink you could not drink
water out of your faucet
because there's there's poop in it
because there's poop in it and within
i don't i don't know 12 hours 24 hours
all bottled water in the city gone like
there's nothing available
and that was a huge pain in the ass
and a massive hassle and for a few
hundred bucks
if you think of all of the things you
waste money on or spend money on
it's very inexpensive insurance
for an event like that which is
demonstrably not
has a non-zero chance of happening and i
remember that with hurricane
sandy back in the day also in new york
yeah and
i mean these things do happen maybe they
happen
as infrequently as a kitchen fire or a
head-on collision but you still have
a fire extinguisher in your kitchen you
still wear your seatbelt when you drive
um yeah i like it that you're pointing
that out it's an interesting thing it's
like no one
thinks you're a whacked-out prepper to
have a fire extinguisher
or to have a first aid kit or
to have uh homeowners insurance
you know it's like why do you use some
kind of
you know right wing right but it's like
yeah it's just i just view it as a a
thing you know it's like a
a peace of mind issue if nothing else
what i used to have when i in you know
seattle gets so much rain
i bought a i use this for my garden
but i i loved it where i bought a 250
gallon
tank that sat under the i had a roof
deck on top of my house
and it came down this downspout it rains
all the damn time you know in the summer
or sorry in the winter and i just rigged
this 250 gallon tank
under my downspout and you could get
you know 10 minutes of rain off that
rooftop and fill that thing up
and i used to love that thing because i
was like i was like dude
it's like a you know bulletproof man as
long as it rains
you mentioned the the dried uh
freeze-dried food
uh there is sort of the good the bad and
the ugly increased dried food do you
have any particular favorites
man it used to be simple like in the old
days
it was like you had a company this
company is the pioneer
of freeze-dried food i wanna tell people
real quick i wanna explain freeze-dried
food to folks
it's an interesting process i wrote a p
i wrote a piece for outside magazine
years ago about
the freeze-dried food industry and
freeze-dried food and i revisited that
article and working on this book just to
get some of it
back straight again but uh during it i
visited when i was working on this
article i visited oregon freeze dry and
oregon freeze dry
is they do all kinds of military
contracting they do
like nasa contracting it was oregon
freeze drive that sent all kinds of
products into outer space
their consumer brand is mountain house
and so mount house is pretty ubiquitous
like you walk into
any sporting goods store or whatever
you'll see i i think it even turns up in
costco you'll see these
square buckets or individual things of
of mountain house and that's a consumer
brand by a by a
major player in the freeze dry food
business what they do is they make
in this process you produce you produce
table ready food okay so let's say
you're making spaghetti with meat sauce
and you're gonna freeze dry it they
actually make
spaghetti and meat sauce so it looks
like
you could sit down and eat it it's ready
to like put in your bowl and serve at
the dinner table
they then spread this out into about an
inch layer
on these big huge sheet trays they just
spread it out about an
inch thick and a giant imagine a giant
cookie sheet with inch thick spaghetti
and meat sauce on it it goes into a
freezer
and they freeze it and like the the
speed at which it freezes is proprietary
there's a lot of magic and like how
quickly you freeze it because you're
trying to
get a certain size ice crystal that's
optimal
for freeze drying but they freeze the
sheet
and then it goes into a sublimation
chamber um these sublimation chambers
bring to mind a
what an amazing name yeah sublimation
chamber
looking at it it looks like the end of a
submarine sticking out of a wall
okay and the sublimation chamber is a
vacuum chamber
so you put all these sheets of frozen
food so you could do
up till now you can do it at your home
right they put these sheets of frozen
food into the sublimation chamber
and they pull a vacuum on it okay and
once they got it once they pull the
strong vacuum on it
they start to slowly warm up
there's like heating coils start to warm
the food up
sublimation means that it's going from a
frozen
that the water goes from a frozen to
gaseous state
under vacuum with the right pressure
so that it skips the water phase
the ice and melting goes directly to gas
and collects on coils
when you pull it out you now have it
doesn't look any different
if you pulled it out of the sublimation
chamber it would look like just how it
went in
except you'd be able to pick it up and
break it like a sheet of glass
it's then you know mashed up crumbled up
and put into a bag
that's freeze dry food shelf life of
you know with the right packaging these
like these like laminated bags the right
packaging on these products you know the
shelf life of 30 years 40 years i think
that
they don't quite know the shelf life
because no one's had any sitting around
long enough you know with the right
packaging to figure it out
there's a love and a hate for freeze
drive the convenience is unbelievable
and there are now many more freeze dry
companies entering the space and they're
all kind of you know whittling away at
mountain house uh
you know uh heather's does the company
have his choice it does some
freeze-dried stuff peak refuel we eat a
lot of that
does dried food there are a bunch of
them out there
and now you can buy your own sublimation
chambers i think for like three or four
thousand bucks and get a sublimation
chamber at your house and make your own
freeze-dried food if you're like super
prepper
yeah a few thousand bucks i was just
camping with a guy whose buddy has his
own sublimation chamber now
and this dude like whenever he makes
dinner he like freeze-dried some too
uh it's a riot
but a lot of people report
and i've experienced those a lot of
people report that there's nothing
harder
on a person's gut than three or four
days where the freeze drive
most anybody can hack a day or two a
freeze-dry
but you get it to a point where just
something different
is going on in the old stomach i don't
know what it is i've had people tell me
that it's not
true it's just true
um
just true i can't tell you why it's true
but it's true
some people thrive on it i do quite well
on it some people it just tears them up
the problem though is that
you cannot misconfuse freeze-dried food
with dehydrated food dehydrated food
can take a lot longer to rehydrate
it can be that you do it you don't get
it fully rehydrated
like dehydrated beans you want to talk
about something messing your gut up
dehydrated beans you haven't gotten
properly
rehydrated can tear you to pieces
freeze dryer hydrates pretty quickly i
got a friend that does a lot of
backcountry travel
and he's a he's a light he's a
minimalist he's a lightweight fanatic he
doesn't carry a camp stove with him
he takes freeze-dried food and around
noon he'll pour
cold water under freeze-dried food
and then just carried around strapped to
his backpack
knowing that about by six or seven hours
it'll have fully rehydrated and he'll
just eat
cold freeze drive if you put hot water
in here that shit's ready in eight
minutes
yeah seven or eight minutes and like i
said you just can't argue with the shelf
life
the stuff came into widespread use with
the lerps in vietnam
long-range reconnaissance patrollers
that was kind of like the pioneering
days of freeze-dried food
and then it had big ramifications for
you know nasa and military use and such
when i was at the oregon freeze-dry
company years ago it was funny because i
was with one of the guys a lab
technician he's like a cook or a chef
you know executive chef whatever there
and we go into this room he goes name it
was like their lab room where they have
everything on the planet freeze-dried
and he's like name something to see if i
have it in here and i'm like i don't
know
uh capers he's like got it you know they
freeze-dry everything experimenting with
it they make freeze-dried shrimp
cocktail
i'm not kidding man cans of freeze-dried
shrimp and freeze-dried cocktail sauce
i don't think that that's i don't know
if that's available to the public but
i have a fascination and a deep love
hate with freeze drive but it is
unparalleled as an emergency food
backpacking food wilderness preparedness
food
it is the best thing going there's
nothing that even
approaches it shelf life i'm looking
online between
25 to 30 years so it was one freeze dry
company when i was working on my article
one freeze drag company i said what's
the shelf life and they said we switched
to this style of bag i can't remember
what it was
so like we switched to this style of bag
30 years ago
it's all still fine uh this that we're
not making a recommendation
i don't know how they handle the
recommendation part of it but they're
like we know that it's at least this but
that's all the longer we've had laying
here
so who knows right it's it's really
really great stuff it's expensive but
it just you know fill up a tote with
that and put it in your garage and it's
just like you
oh you don't need to check it you keep
mice out of there
you don't need to check it you your kids
will have emergency food
oh my god and uh a note on
freeze drying for folks who just want to
play with something
the freezer in your home
is at least for a lot of folks will be
the driest place
in your home which is counterintuitive
for a lot of folks so you can take if
you want to get a really good sear on a
steak
you can actually put it on a drying
tray or rack of some type in your
freezer for
say 30 minutes 30 might be too long like
15
20 minutes before you cook to
to dry off the surface of the steaks
my yard reaction when searing so that's
a that's a trick that people can also
use
it seems that there's evidence of the
incans
doing something similar to freeze drying
with potatoes i don't remember the
details on it but they would
store potatoes or there are instances
where potatoes were stashed or stored
you know 10 000 feet and
preserved through freeze drying and they
would also
do an equivalent of
they would sometimes put human remains
up 10 11 000 feet and
i don't know if you've ever i went to
saul to argentina to visit
those incan children that they're
there's kind of a famous story these
three incan children that were put in a
little rock shelter
at very high elevation so perfectly
preserved
that you could still see coca leaves on
one of the kids lips it looks like they
could just wake up from a nap and walk
away
oh they think that those children are
from the 1490s
wow perfectly preserved like they
basically like
naturally freeze dried at high elevation
um they they display
one of these children at a time in salt
to argentina
one of them was struck by at some point
in time
one of them was struck by lightning and
their hair was burned but they have
beautiful
feathers beautiful clothing all
perfectly preserved it's incredible
wow i'm looking at images right now this
is
creepy yeah
it's like something out of the horror
movie the ring
wow yeah there was an issue that they
they don't out of a
out of an agreement with the indigenous
peoples
they will not display all three at once
and so i believe they rotate the display
unless that's changed when i went there
to see one of these children you could
only see one
i wonder why i guess the uh related to
some
mythology or superstition or belief
system of the indigenous i suppose
when they looked at the
they did some work there and when they
look at the
stable you know you can tell people
about people's historic diet
it seems as though those children if i'm
remembering correctly it seems as though
those children spent most their lives
eating primarily potatoes had a very
poor diet for most their lives
but in the year or so leading up to
their death
they had like a phenomenally diverse
diet
and they had with them gifts and
trinkets from
all over the incan empire and perhaps
they were on a sort of tour
being honored across the empire
festivals and being fed and honored
across the empire
before being brought up and killed on
that hilltop the oldest one had been
given a blow to the head with a hatchet
but the other ones they appear to just
have been drunk
they were drunk on a some kind of
fermented drink
and maybe just passed out and left
except for one of them they had to give
a knock to the head
it's a wild story anyways freeze freeze
dried freeze-dried food
free freeze-dried children don't eat
them
mummies of jujiako with the double
l's i'm saying it with the since it's
argentine but the children
of zhu zhaiko which i'll link to in the
show notes
that's incredible no it was i would like
to
in in a perfect world i'd go back two
more times to see the other
see the other children so
i feel like we can't end on this
particular story
oh that was a real digression but go
ahead pick something yeah yeah
we uh well let's uh let's talk about
what you or let's not let us let you
tell me about what you hope and feel
the psychological benefits will be
from those uh or for those who read
the new book the mediator guide to
wilderness skills and survival
and actually take
steps to practice
some of what's in the book to equip
themselves and some of the ways
described in the book i'm just thinking
to your story about your son with the
truck
but what what do you hope or expect the
the benefits would be psychologically
for people who do this
yeah i hope and expect and anticipate
that people who spend time with the book
will come away feeling more comfortable
feeling comfortable and prepared
in wild places and better able to go
with
friends loved ones colleagues children
what have you into nature into the
wilderness
and not have a you know maybe a
vague sense of foreboding
about something happening or feeling
that
you're in over your skis or as we'd like
to say in over your waders
that when approaching a frozen pond
they instead of looking at it like this
unknown
super dangerous thing that you doesn't
go near
you would look at it as a thing that's
comprehendable
that there are some simple things you
can do to determine is this safe for me
to be on
if i do make a mistake and go there and
something happens i know what to do
i know how to do proper risk assessment
that when you're out camping you're not
having
baseless fears of getting mauled by a
mountain lion
you're not running around with concepts
in your head about how to deter
animal attacks that are one unwarranted
or two the opposite of what you ought to
do if you were in that situation
because i think that even if none of the
bad
things if none of the oh [ __ ] things
that can befall a person happen to you
outdoors
and even if i can come and tell you
statistically they won't
they still live in your head there's
still an anxiety
that people suffer around nature
and around the unexplored
around the unusual and once you arm
yourself
with a mental tool kit and a physical
toolkit at times
you wind up feeling better and once you
feel better and you get that
cockiness you get what a a friend of
mine calls you wilderness swagger
everything goes more smoothly for you
you're able to do
and focus on the things that you came
there to do and focus on
so by being prepared you do away with
the nagging sense in the back of your
head
of what would i do if it just frees you
up
so i just want people to be have that
liberated
swaggering feeling outside
dig it okay last last or maybe second to
last question and this could be a dead
end but
if you were a cyborg just executing on
commands you'd have a certain kit a
certain approach should be super
methodical
all highly rational is there anything
peculiar
you take with you on some of your trips
or anything absurd
that you feel compelled to do
that would not be in the textbook
instruction manual related to skills and
survival
anything uh particularly
steve varnella that that your friends or
companions
in the wilderness make fun of you for uh
man i'm going to approach in a slightly
different way and this is this is brand
new fresh information
i have a friend who's a very avid alpine
hunter
and he uses and likes crampons
okay i had always shied away could you
describe what
describe what those are for folks yeah
crampons are like a thing you you lock
onto your boot strap onto your boot it's
cleats
like very very aggressive like nothing
like a golf cleat like
steel or aluminum spikes
that are used for extru like they're
used for ice climbing
extreme mountaineering okay i know he's
always been a fan of crampons
i'd always been under the feeling that i
didn't use crampons in the mountains
typically because i thought that
crampons are things people use
more to get themselves into trouble than
to get themselves out of trouble
meaning uh you know some basic repelling
skills
are good to have right that's something
we cover but
i don't advise for just normal people
like normal use outside of
mountaineering i don't advise
using that to get somewhere i would
advise using that to like you got
somewhere and now you're like oh
and you used to get out and i thought
crampons were potentially troublemaking
that it would give you it would give you
know the wilderness swagger i mentioned
it'd give you too much swagger and you'd
wind up doing [ __ ] that you should not
do
and so i was with him and i finally
brought a set of crampons and i came
away from it like holy [ __ ] because
even just on a steep pitch
where there's some wet snow i used to
take for granted that you walked along
side hilling along a steep pitch with
wet snow i used to take for granted that
you just ate [ __ ]
right every other step this is just like
how it goes
you know and it'd be like five steps
whoop five steps whoop
and putting those on i became a believer
so
quickly in like moving around
on wet grass icy stuff
how that allowed you to just grease
through areas that i used to view as
being hard to get
through so i could see now being a guy
at the trailhead with a set of crampons
strapped to my pack and other people at
the trailhead being like
what is this idiot doing
the same way a month ago if i saw
someone with crampons i'd be like oh
come on
come on really
really and now i'll be like
if i see that dude i'm gonna be like
yeah bro
right on i get you i gotcha
what adventure have you
up to this point left unrequited like
you've had
so many trips so many adventures
so much travel so much outdoor
wilderness time
what is still on the bucket list for you
oh that's an easy one
there's a there's a river in
south america that i've done
two river trips on and i was able to
do these river trips with a group
called the the makushi a tribe called
the makushi they have a few villages
along this river
it's a long long river and
they talk about the
head of this river there's a couple of
them that have been there
most of the guys haven't been there and
they talk about the head of this
river as being like what they regard as
like kind of like the most magical place
on the planet
and the lower end of this river where
i've been blows my mind
and they have this attitude like you
haven't seen [ __ ]
you've been up but you gotta have about
three you know it's three week trip
to get up because you gotta portage
around all these waterfalls i don't have
a concrete plan yet
but at whatever point in life that you
sort of like
approach retirement but you still have
your physical capabilities
i want to go up that damn river
until it's a trickle like ideally i'd go
with my brothers
i won't go up that river so damn bad
like i think about it all
the time
to the other end to the bitter end
like i said to where it comes out of a
rock and like
that's my thing that i want to do and
these guys live off fish when they're
traveling too and i like fish
that's a win-win steve always fun always
a good time
and you're making me want to get out
into the wilderness
asap and actually to
do a fair amount of prep beforehand so
i'm not just yet another idiot
wandering out with with no plan no
contingencies
no nothing and i'm excited about the
book
i'm really thrilled that you were able
to carve out some time today
is there anything else that you would
like to say
complaints comments requests for the
audience
closing inspirational quotes anything at
all before we
bring this to a close at the top of
mount everest
it's marine limestone that's it
thank you very much tim got i got enough
yeah you covered it
all right stephen vanella folks the
meateater.com
at meateater on instagram at
stephenranella with a
v stephen r-i-n-e-l-l-a the new book is
the mediator guide to wilderness skills
and survival i will also
link to everything we've discussed in
the show notes at tim.blog forward slash
podcast
until next time thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this podcast is
brought to you by the ready state
virtual mobility coach what on earth is
that well let me back up
the first person i personally call for
help with my athletic recovery or
mobility training is dr kelly starrett
at the ready state
i've known kelly for more than a decade
i was introduced to him
for a bunch of reasons i've seen him
perform near miracles
on me and many others he's a good friend
but he's also a mobility
and movement coach for olympic gold
medalists world champions and pro
athletes
you might recognize the name because
kelly was in the four hour body
he was in tools of titans he's been on
this podcast
he also nursed and coached me through
the destroy my body for entertainment tv
show that
was the tim ferriss experiment and i
made it through
those 13 episodes because of kelly would
not have survived
now kelly has created a program called
virtual mobility coach it's like
carrying a virtual kelly starrett in
your pocket because
most people are not going to have direct
access to kelly but now
you do every day virtual mobility coach
gives you guided mobility videos
walks you step by step through kelly's
proven techniques
to relieve pain improve range of motion
improve performance
on and on and on and on there are a lot
of things you can do with this program
and you gotta check it out it's
encyclopedic but simultaneously really
easy to navigate
if you're in pain you can pull up a
picture of your body click on what hurts
and from there
get customized regimen to help find
relief
if you are working out or playing a
sport virtual mobility coach offers all
sorts of pre
and post exercise mobility sequences for
more than 50 sports and activities
actually so those will help you warm up
before your workout so you can run
faster jump higher lift heavier all with
a lower risk of injury
and if you're not in pain or working out
virtual mobility coach also has a
library of daily maintenance videos
great way to speed up recovery on your
off days which also helps a lot with
sleep and much of that stuff
and right now listeners of this podcast
get a special deal you can try
virtual mobility coach you can get the
kelly starrett in your pocket
totally risk-free for two weeks without
paying a penny it is a two-week
free trial so you should try it out
kelly is super legit
he is literally the person i text and
call
with the most sophisticated slash
esoteric questions about recovery and
injuries i've inflicted upon myself
he knows what he's doing and his stuff
really really works try it completely
free for two weeks and if you decide to
continue
you can get 10 off for life using promo
code
tim10 that's tim10
simply visit therestate.com tim to check
everything out
and use code tim10 at checkout again
that's the readystate.com
tim and use code 1010 when you sign up
to get 10 off for the life of your
membership
after your 14 day free trial ends the
readystate.com
temp this episode is brought to you by
99 designs
the global creative platform that makes
it easy for you to find and work with
amazing graphic designers online
long time listeners of this podcast know
how much attention i paid to detail
how obsessively i approach nearly all
elements of my work
because the small things often end up
being the big things so whether it's
your logo
your business cards website design even
your email templates all of these visual
elements
tell your customers tell your users who
you are and what you're about
so i think it's worth sweating the
details i've been using 99designs for
years now to ensure that many of my
creative projects whether big or small
are as cohesive professional and
beautiful as possible
i've worked on draft mock-ups of book
covers
i've worked on all sorts of things most
recently i've been working with a
designer
at 99designs to update the illustrations
and layouts for all of my downloadable
ebooks
i've developed a really great working
relationship with designer who goes by
the username spoonlancer and i intend to
continue working with him to bring ideas
to life
one project at a time i've also used 99
designs for all sorts
of high-end illustration for different
books like the tao of seneca you can see
a bunch of examples on my instagram that
i've put up
and they've turned out better than i
possibly could have hoped
so from logos to websites to packaging
to books
99designs is the go-to creative resource
to build your brand on any budget
so check them out right now my listeners
that's you guys can get 20
off plus a free 99 upgrade on
their first design contest contest is a
great way to get started and find the
right designer
for long-term work you can also book a
free design consultation with a brand
expert at 99designs to receive
personalized branding advice over the
phone
their hands-on team has helped thousands
of business owners at this point it's a
great way to get the most out of your
experience with 99designs
so take a look head to 99designs.com
tim for your discount and to sign up for
design consultation
today that's 99designs.com